le festival du film romantique qui vient
de se terminer à cabourg sur la côte
normande les organisateurs avaient
inscrit à leur programme une
rétrospective des films de jean tierney
toujours le même regard toujours le même
sourire lorsque nicole cornu langlois et
pierre lepetit l'ont rencontré et voici
jean tueursnet symbole du star system de
la période faste hollywoodienne qui
inspira les plus grands réalisateurs
john ford mankiewicz ou lubich elle
fusilla la femme arabe de sand and
d'henry hathaway et puis laura d'otto
preminger et tant d'autres héroïnes
fatale
on est content que j'étais là et j'ai vu
j'ai su que j'ai évoqué le mini vous
avez un merveilleux souvenir de cinéma
nous raconter non pas juste les airs
sans longue il faut une somme sur des
faits ce que je n'aime pas mais j'ai
tourné en dix quinze ans
car enfin agir pour cette adresse ici et
les venues ici au festival de cabourg
sont la promenade de proust c'est
qu'elle aime un certain style de cinéma
rgfm moment ainsi qu'est ce que c'est
pour eux leurs motifs
oui quand les gens si on lit les cd a
lancé quand la violence en effet elle
abandonna longtemps le cinéma dépression
internement elle le raconte dans
mademoiselle vous devriez faire du
cinéma un livre pour aider les autres
assumer leurs propres malheurs l'instant
en otage je les fait ôter de la moi ou
c'est s'est crashé polycom un grand
besoin de vos rangs une chose dont on
peut pas en taule et j'espère que ça
fait du bien aux autres
j'ai eu l'aide d'une dame qui était si
gentil ali j'ai plus de temps à autre je
souffrais livre parce que c'est un ami
un des foyers spéciaux vous proposer un
rôle maintenant vraiment qui vous
plaisent beaucoup
est-ce que vous accepteriez de tourner
maintenant oui bon accessoire y est
maintenant
producteurs et réalisateurs peuvent
faire confiance à jean pierre n'est elle
fascine aussi la nouvelle génération
etienne daho vient de lui dédier une
chanson